what happens when you take the kid from
my girl and mix it with ruth langmore
from ozark in order to find out you're
gonna have to
kill me
i'm sorry i just wanted to use that clip
well i just finished shonda rhimes
latest netflix show inventing anna based
on the real story of anna sorokin who
stole hundreds of thousands of dollars
from some of new york's wealthiest and
almost got away with acquiring a 25
million dollar loan but the biggest
crime here is actually how much better a
show inventing anna could have been so
grab a vip pass and make sure to like
and subscribe because it's vip don't you
know how vip works now i just have to
say it i think this show could have been
an amazing two hour movie i mean when i
first heard they were doing a limited
series on this and a woman i was excited
because who doesn't like to see rich
[ __ ] get scammed out of millions
that's the part that lured me in it's
the fun of the show and the way it was
marketed but inventing anna focuses more
on anna's friendships than it does on
the con itself just take a look at
episode 1 anna's only in it for about 10
minutes of its hour-long run time and
it's not until episode 4 that we get
into anna's main con acquiring the
multi-million dollar loan you could
probably cut the first three episodes
entirely and the show would still work
but hey shonda has this netflix deal and
she has to stretch out those stories by
focusing on the journalists and anna's
friends you take away from the very
reason many of us were brought into the
show the con and when you add the fact
these characters aren't compelling nor
do we care about them the show drags and
i gotta tell you i really didn't care
about anna she's extremely unlikable a
pretentious narcissist who sees the
world in terms of rich and poor and if
you're poor well you might as well be
sub-human she's extremely manipulative
on two different occasions she tells her
friends she'll commit suicide if they
don't help her and while on the phone
with her lawyer's son gives him the
great advice that the two most powerful
tools to get money are guilt and love
that's not to say an unlikable character
like anna can't be compelling to watch
some of the greatest characters in film
and tv history are not good people
you're goddamn right it's anna's
brazenness to take on the wealthy elite
however that draws us to her it's a
shame then that much of the show is
bloated by plot that isn't about this in
fact anna isn't even the protagonist
that title belongs to vivian kent whose
character is based off the author who
wrote the article the show draws from
because anna is such a static character
she doesn't go through any
transformative change over the course of
the season the anna at the beginning of
the series is the same anna at the end
she doesn't have any remorse for what
she's done in fact she says her only
mistake was to overestimate people's
ability to handle stress
your only mistake and the cherry on top
one of anna's final lines to vivian i
don't like you you have terrible shoes
this was a transaction we had to deal
because anna doesn't undergo a change
that falls on vivian who is the show's
real protagonist this change should be
the impetus for us to care about her
journey but the show hides the very
reason we should be rooting for her
vivienne was involved in a botched
journalism piece which branded her as a
bad journalist this resulted in her
losing her dream job at bloomberg and
why she was sent to scriberia where
older writers live out their remaining
days if you wanted us to really care
about vivian and empathize with her
drive to make sure the anna piece is a
hit show us this moment don't hide it
show us her being ridiculed show us her
losing her dream job right as she finds
out she's pregnant and her ability to
support the child now in jeopardy let's
watch her get ruined so it
contextualizes her motivation to succeed
this has the added effect of the viewer
connecting with her because who among us
hasn't been in a situation where we've
had things about us misrepresented or
we've been down and out through no fault
of our own the same goes with anna's
friends there isn't really anything
interesting about them and i found
myself half the time yelling at the
screen wondering how they could still
stick by her after all these lies but i
want to segue into something a little
different who do you think the villain
in the show is is it anna the wealthy
new yorkers the assistant d.a honestly
i'm not sure what the show is wanting me
to think the final episode plays out as
a sympathy hail mary for anna the old
writers cheer when anna is found not
guilty on two of the counts but anna was
guilty she's a criminal why are they
cheering for her but this also leads
into what exactly the show is trying to
say is conning okay if it allows you to
realize your dreams and no one gets hurt
can't be that lots of people did get
hurt is it about a woman taking on the
patriarchy and acting like a modern day
robin hood as her lawyer describes can't
be that either anna only cares about
herself and even steals from her friends
so even though there are elements of
social justice like this scene where
trump's state of the union plays in the
background there's zero consequences for
these men it feels more like an
afterthought than part of the overall
thematic argument the show is trying to
make on a personal note and this just
might be me i didn't like the tone there
are scenes that are just downright goofy
like when neff scares rachel and she
runs away or this one she used my
bathroom and i didn't have any toilet
paper and she did a number two and the
odor
was
incredible the vibe felt like a
broadcast show which i didn't think this
subject matter was deserving of but
perhaps the biggest scam of this whole
show is that netflix paid the real anna
322 thousand dollars for the rights to
her story granted much of that went to
her paying off legal fees but it just
goes to show you that even when she was
in jail anna could make a few bucks now
i know i'm being a bit harsh on the show
but that's because i thought it could
have been so much better especially with
shonda rhimes and julia garner behind it
if you do want to see some shows i
absolutely hated well i have a whole
playlist for that but i want to hear
what you thought about inventing anna
did you enjoy it was it meh i want to
hear your thoughts in the comments below
thanks for watching everyone be sure to
like and subscribe and for more bad
takes you can follow me on twitter and
instagram at thinkstoryyt until next
time remember you're gonna have to
[ __ ] kill that
you